parlant de vacances on peut dire que
l'année dernière avec geneviève on n'a
pas passé des vacances idiote quoi on
peut dire qu'on a passé des vacances
culturelles nous avons été au pays
desquels mouthe et là nous avons
rencontré un artiste je vais vous
montrer
est ce un travail artisanal un simple
chapeau de mariage pour hommes faits à
la main je vous la beauté de la forme
le jeune marié se coiffe de ce chapeau
pour aller chercher sa promise
et ils sont d'une noblesse parce que
c'est un très beau peuple quel quel
dommage que j'ai été malade
oui j'étais même parce que je ne
supportais pas leur cuisine parce que ce
sont des gens qui mangent comme il y a
deux mille ans et ça fait quand même un
poids mais c'est un peuple musiciens
écoutez je vous faire entendre une
chanson de berger que j'ai pu noter un
jour que je reposerai près d'une source
parce que j'avais eu un phlegmon enfin
l'histoire du ch n'ont su d'une longue
histoire j'ai un contrat voici donc
cette chanson de berger qui est un
document brut
je vous le précise christian christian
pourriez-vous m'accompagner avec le qui
coulait regardez le quai couler un
travail artisanal et qui coule
un cri couler des qui coula
voici donc cette chanson qui était
documents bruts je le précise
c'est un chant d'amour
les jeunes gens se chante ça de
montagnat montagne
évidemment dans une salle ça rend pas
très bien mais nous continuons dé
christian il me semble que nous sommes
pas accorder tous les deux
hop hop hop hop
christian souvenez vous qu'il ya quand
même une garde ainsi il ya une gamme
genève à la bague accusé d'aller au
mariage
on laisse tomber alors l'envié d'oublier
la fin de la chanson
ah oui le berger n'a pas chanté cette
chanson jusqu'au bout parce que il s'est
endormi
mais avant de s'endormir il a chanté
encore quelques mesures que voici
le face à un autre travail artisanal
le fap à 1 face à des facile
oui alors c'est pour chasser les mouches
parce que là bas vous avez des grosses
mouches bleues très tenace et si vous
avez une mouche au coin de la bouche
vous pouvez pas l'enlever avec un petit
geste gracieux comme ça faut vraiment
très très fort
le lendemain de ma maladie je suis sorti
je suis sorti sans le phare mouche ici
bas le fait qu'on aille parce que ça
c'est une chose qu'il faut noter c'est
que dans ce pays tout prend des
proportions et non ça n'a plus rien à
voir avec les dimensions de la france si
vous avez des montagnes qui démontrait
non
et quand vous avez un pigment vous avez
le vêtement et christian c'est comme les
coups de soleil avec geneviève on a eu
des coups de soleil
eh bien nous avons été brûlé au deuxième
degré et alors là on a été transporté de
toute urgence à l'hôpital à dos de
chameau il a à l'hôpital on a eu un
accueil d'une gentillesse mais c'était
gentil mais vous voulez pas savoir
christian dans cet hôpital un accueil
tellement hospitaliers et les fêtes
gentillesse pour ne pas nous déranger
toute la nuit les infirmiers chantait
mais à mi voix et le matin vous aviez
l'équipe de jours qui arrivent et
vaillamment et là toute la journée
l'apport
le cheval yeux par exemple un infirmier
qui me faisait des piqûres toutes les
deux heures
c'était il ya lieu puis on les a bien
connu avec geneviève on les a bien connu
parce que on est resté à l'hôpital
beaucoup plus longtemps quand tu croyais
pas ce qu'ils ont découvert qu'on avait
attrapé des animes à l'attention des
amis d'achat mot à dire des bestioles
énorme comme ça et tenez vous bien ce
sont des amis qu'il s'attaque jamais à
l'eau est souvent aux touristes mais
tout est beau la part tout et pour
l'architecturé vous ai parlé du temple
de rab la question
vous n'êtes pas prêt le temple de la
question je les ai eus de la fenêtre de
l'ambulance qui m'a mené aux grands
brûlés mais tout est beau leur écriture
aux avis zone écriture la lettre je vais
vous montrer j'ai un paquet de
ordonnance que je vais vous délivrer la
officiant plus voir ça c'est la fameuse
photo que cherchait par tous elle est
formidable mais je vois que ça vous
intéresse regarder alors ça c'est
geneviève et moi à l'aéroport voyez sur
nos grands car derrière la en arc de
cercle se sont tous les infirmiers qui
se marre
et ici c'est le docteur ma couche le
docteur baccouche un joyeux lurons poule
va savoir
c'est lui qui faisait pendant mon
opération noté